meanwhile the Pentagon says it's now
deploying additional air defense systems
throughout the Middle East in response
to recent escalations let's speak to
Heidi Jo Castro in Washington DC for
more on that Heidi two aircraft carrier
strike groups now this and I see even
more troops are being put on higher
alert is this deterrence or does it
potentially go further than
that nasia according to the defense
secretary's announcement about this new
deployment he says this is about
deterrence about keeping this conflict
within Israel and Gaza and not having it
spread wider however you look at the
things that the US is now sending two
groundbased missile defense systems
while President Biden has said he will
not be putting US troops on the ground
in Israel so it really makes you wonder
where these systems would go of course
the US does have troops in the region
there's 2500 in uh Iraq another 900 in
Syria and of course just earlier this
week some of those troops came under
attack from drones so potentially these
systems could go there of course just
off of the coast of Israel in the
Mediterranean we have those two aircraft
aircraft carriers as you said with some
thousands of personnel aboard but
certainly sending these groundbased
missile defense systems may show uh
further escalation of this even though
the US still is Fring it as deterrence
Heidi just how much public support does
Biden have now for stepping up us
mobilization to back
Israel that's right now given his
promise to the American public that
there would no be would not be us boots
on the ground in this there was a poll
taken earlier in the week by
quinnipeague to Aid Israel in its
defense and Biden is using that
sentiment he's asking Congress for uh an
additional $4 billion to Aid Israel uh
that's what he's asking on paper in
practice it's going to be difficult
given that right now the US Congress is
at a standstill for the lack of a house
speaker and forgiv uh budget fights that
are likely to be on the horizon but at
this moment sentiment in the US does
appear to be on the support of on the
side of supporting Israel further Heidi
Jo Castro with all the latest for us
there from Washington DC thank you
Heidi